finale nous allons rester aux états unis
d'une certaine manière pour vous parler
du véritable tabac café
là-bas la patrouille de france à
l'occasion de la commémoration de la
statue de la liberté la patrie de la
patrouille de france avait traversé
l'atlantique
il paraît que les hommes qui pilote ces
avions extrêmement rapide
on était très très bien accueilli par le
public américain
nous allons en parler tout à l'heure en
compagnie de laurent boursiers et du
patron de la patrouille de france
ils sont en direct avec nous à marseille
bonjour bonjour laurent bonjour
messieurs voilà
mais auparavant on va regarder le
reportage que vous avez réalisé laurent
sur la patrouille de france aux états
unis via les voir de la belle image est
si beau miss liberty en est encore tout
retourné
pensez alors qu'elle fêtait
tranquillement ses 100 ans le 4 juillet
dernier huit petit avion français de
surcroît sont venus virevolter au dessus
de sa tête
on lui a dit c'est la patrouille de
france
la france ça lui disait bien quelque
chose mais c'était assez lointain par
contre tout proche d'elle les alphajet
bleu-blanc-rouge réussi s'est
brillamment leur rentrée aux états unis
en effectuant ce jour-là un show qui
soulevait l'enthousiasmé
c'était une première pour les pilotes
français c'était évidemment une première
pour les new yorkais
seul patrouilles étrangères à évoluer
dans le ciel new yorkais pendant les
cérémonies
elle devait après un voyage de plus de
dix mille kilomètres qui l'avait amené
de salon de provence à new york en
passant par l'ecosse l'islande et le
canada effectué quatre représentations
quatre jours qui selon le new york
police department été suivi par plus de
3 millions de personnes chaque
représentation duré 20 minutes pendant
lesquelles dix sept figures différentes
étaient effectués
le guen
dix sept figures qui de la flèche ôter
au diamant en passant par les passages
en solo se terminait toujours par
l'éclatement bleu blanc rouge face au
public
après new york les huit alphajet de la
paf entendait la patrouille aérienne
françaises ont entamé un long périple
qui devait les conduire dans le new
hampshire à chicago sur la côte ouest
des états unis los angeles' crise puis
au canada ottawa et north bay avant de
revenir sur la côte est
en tout plus de vingt mille kilomètres
parcourus sur le continent nord
américain
des dizaines d'aéroports et de base
aérienne visiter
oui
en un mois une quinzaine de
représentations ont été effectués devant
des spectateurs de plus en plus nombreux
un exemple en survolant les chutes du
niagara les alpha jet ont créé a
volontairement un embouteillage
monstrueux due à des conducteurs
descendus de leur voiture pour voir
évoluer les avions un succès confirmé
par la presse et les télévisions
américaines
les journalistes y voyant un cadeau de
la france au peuple américain
comme à l'aller le voyage de retour
s'est effectué par le nord le canada le
groenland l'islande l'ecosse et enfin
pour terminer salon de provence